nous avons essayé de répondre à cette
question nous tournant vers l'homme du
xxième siècle docteur salomon ce sera
notre dernière question comment
envisagez-vous le visage donc de cet
homme du 21e siècle a dit avec beaucoup
d'optimisme mais avec un optimisme très
vite parce que ça ne se vend pas sans
mal par les révolutions je crois pas à
une apocalypse nucléaire mais il y aura
beaucoup de bouleversements
mais l'homme du xxième siècle sera amené
à une certaine convivialité parce que la
planète est tout petit
parce que les ressources s'épuisent et
parce que ce selon des fameuses
expérience sur la densité des poissons
dans un bocal n'avons pas le temps d'en
parler ici la partie d'un certain seuil
une certaine coexistence établi on passe
de la de la planète telle qu'elle est à
la planète bateau lui il faut délimiter
l'espace et acquérir un nouveau code de
conduite
ce nouveau code de conduite nous sommes
très reconnaissants d'avoir bien voulu
l'ex crise est avec nous et puis vous
pourrez vous qui se vous y intéressez
essayé d'en savoir plus dans cet ouvrage
absolument passionnant que le docteur
seulement donc a publié sous le titre
l'avenir de la vie et vous pourrez y
voir en particulier que il y as question
de l'avenir de la vie dans l'espace car
l'espace représente évidemment et peut
être même le milieu privilégié pour un
développement futur
la vie car en fait et 1985 des hommes
travailleront en permanence dans
l'espace et ils vivront des périodes
assez longues
et puis à partir du début du xxième
siècle des bases permanentes seront
installés soit autour de la terre soit
sur d'autres mondes dans le système
solaire
et tout ceci permettra à l'homme de
pénétrer un milieu nouveau mais un
milieu qui est quand même extrêmement
hostile pas de pesanteur des
températures inférieures à 270 degrés en
dessous de zéro pas de limites physiques
tangibles et ceci évidemment étant
ajouté sur ajouter par le fait qu'il y à
des agresseurs extrêmement nombreux dans
ce milieu tout d'abord des rayons
cosmiques dont certains sont extrêmement
dangereux et puis également des gars
stellaire de toute nature et enfin des
poussières dans certaines contiennent
des micro organismes des particules
organiques pour se protéger contre ce
milieu l'homme devra effectivement
inventé un certain nombre de barrières
ce sera la médecine spatiale de le faire
des barrières qu'ils protégeront sur le
plan physique également sur le plan
psychique et peut-être même devra-t-il
être modifié dans sa structure
biologique qui sait
[Musique]